i mean i got a mind of my own if you
want to put everybody on the spot i
gotta put you on the spot
what it's only fair see that's really
[Music]
nothing
i'm headed to portland oregon to
interview
portland trailblazers star damian
lillard so we're going out west to
find out what he thinks for
see you in six himself going over my
notes about dame one more time before we
land
[Music]
made it to portland and it is raining of
course
i met up with dame at the blazers
practice facility
[Music]
you got to hold up to this camera like a
pro
good
what is it like playing in the western
conference
it's a war zone every game is tough
who's the most fatal opponent in that
war zone i think golden state
because you can beat golden state for
three and a half quarters
it could be six minutes left you have 15
and
they will erase that lead in two minutes
i think where people get it mixed up
is when they allow that to turn into a
fear factor
i think sometimes people fear them
and when they sense that little bit of
fear
you're done you got to go out there and
play against them like you know you're
going to beat them
give them something to think about how
did it feel to be swept in the opening
out of the playoffs in 2018.
that was the one that really stung
because
not only were our expectations so high
to make a push
but we lost in the first round and we
got swept with home court advantage so
it was like after we lost in new orleans
i was just hurt for like
a month i was just i didn't want to
watch basketball or nothing i just was
hurt
okay so every guest i have i ask you to
take me to
a place that is what we are going to do
right now you ready
okay take me to your first tattoo my mom
was dropping me off at school it was the
day before
my first day of college we went to the
mall
and there was a tattoo shopping there we
walked in and i got my first tattoo
and it was like the warner brothers sign
but it was
a lb instead of a wb and i got lily
brothers above it so my brother
got the same tattoo and that was my
first tattoo
take me to the first music album you
bought the first album i bought was
um the block is hot lil wayne the block
is hot
the black is hot
take me to the time that you realized
college scouts were wrong about you
i went to adidas nations in chicago
after my sophomore year
and i had a real good camp but then like
after the camp was over they did like
all the evaluations and they was like
yeah you know
not really a good junk shooter off the
drill it was like
it was stuff that i really you're like
known for now like i didn't take it
personal but i was like i really
disagreed with it i was like no i don't
think i don't agree with that yeah and
um
that was the first time i was like they
wrong like they run like
they hating that was like it was typical
but i was like they hate i never told
nobody i felt that way
[Applause]
social media went kind of crazy after a
quote came out where you were talking
about not wanting to sell yourself out
for titles
like i'm saying i do want to win a
championship but it's other stuff that
means more to me got you i don't know
it's almost like i'm not willing to sell
myself out
for that i don't feel i need to prove to
anybody how bad i want to win it
because it shows in my work it shows in
my approach to the game
i'm not gonna go and try to team up with
top players in the league
because i know that'll make the chances
better because that's not who i am
you know i'm a get it out the mud type
of person
it's been a good time to have to work
and grind and do all this stuff for
everything that i get because when i get
it i'm like
i worked for this i earned it and it's a
it's more gratifying you know what i'm
saying so
on the outside they're gonna say oh
he'll never win in portland
they don't have enough they don't have
this but to me it's like
if we never get it done you never get it
done
[Applause]
so is it accurate to say that failure
for you isn't not getting a ring failure
for you is not being who you are
exactly some of the best players ever i
was watching um
michael rappaport and he was talking
about when you think about
gary payton you never think about him in
miami winning the ring
you think about gary payton in seattle
and alan iverson
in philly like you just think about
their legacy and what they did
for me like i said i just focus on what
means something to me
working for it and if it don't happen i
can live with it knowing that you know
my the effort
and the care was there you know i went
after it so this
way that you live it seems as though you
have a code
that you live by basically what
is that code i mean i think it's pretty
simple man just
stay true you know if you famous your
professional athlete celebrity whatever
you want to call it
and it's easy to do things that you
might not do i'm not willing to do
the other stuff and step outside of
being true to myself because that's just
not
just not who i am
but this want to be
loyal and stay true to who you are to me
seems very unique especially for an nba
player
i mean i got a mind of my own and
i'm kind of just comfortable in my skin
i'm comfortable with who i am so
i know that i'm so much more than a
basketball player for one so
for somebody to have criticisms or
comments or whatever about me as a
basketball player that's
that's perfectly fine
[Applause]
if it came down to it would you want to
be remembered as being a loyal person
or would you want to remember it as
being a champion well i think we all
want to be a champion
a nba champion you know that's different
than
just being a champion life when i'm done
playing and when i walk away
nobody could ever say nothing bad about
me other than he didn't win a ring
but he was the realest dude that i
worked with even when he was a max
player
he was always solid with me and they'll
respect me and appreciate me past my
career for that
how much of this code that you live by
is based off the way you grew up in
oakland
i think there's naturally an attitude of
people from oakland is just like
i'm gonna appreciate the battle and the
hard times
so when i overcome all of it to feel
better
but i think it's just the foundation of
my family
my aau team i played for the oakland
rebels and
the rebels we had to do fundraising and
just so we can afford
plane tickets and team shoes and to go
play in these tournaments in vegas and
la and all that stuff
and it's another team across town the
oakland soldiers they get all the best
players
and when i got to high school i became
one of the best players in the bay area
and they wanted me to come play on a
team
what do you think i said i think you
said no
no i stayed with the same aau
program that used to pick me up from the
bart station and give me rides home
and when i didn't have no money paid for
my food like i was loyal to the people
and the environment that i was in what
was the best part
about growing up in oakland i went to
college in utah and when i got there
i was just ready for it because i had
been around so much
i had been around gangs
and gun violence and drugs and
numbers and money everybody in college
was more
kind of naive and i was like man
like oakland really is sped up it's fast
out there so you
you know that growing up in oakland you
can survive anywhere i got robbed at
gunpoint in 12th grade
but it is tough when you grow up and
there's people out there that
be in the streets the reason that i was
able to be successful and
kind of deal with that environment and
still move on and have good grades in
high school and go to college and stuff
like that
is because of the kind of family i come
from i would come home from school
and i got 10 cousins at my grandmother's
house
we all do our homework we had to park we
outside together and then at some point
somebody getting in trouble why you got
a c minus
if i misuse a word my van is like
what did that word mean use it in a
sentence past and present
i had that type of family that like
challenged me on so many different
levels that it was like
i really had no choice but to be some
type of successful and
i just think it's not fair that
a lot of the kids majority of the kids
in my neighborhood just didn't have that
[Music]
what kind of parent do you want to be i
want to be
a great parent but i want to be the kind
of parent
where everything that i'm suggesting or
teaching my son i can also represent
that
i don't want to have to deal with them
challenging me on stuff that i've taught
him and then i'm not doing it myself so
i want to just
i want to be a great example especially
with him being an african-american
man alumni are the slums i'm polished
ain't no removing that straight up out
of oakland we're knowledging all the
shooters at them hooping and producing
now they saying that dude can rap i seen
it all right before my eyes now saluda
mac
how much joy do you get from making
music and being an artist
i get so much joy out of making music i
think because
through the music i'm able to express
myself and i can do it in a creative way
music gives people like a vibe gives
them a feeling
when i listen to music and i'm hearing
people say their lyrics i take myself to
what they
now you're genuinely a good rapper you
really feel that way
one hundred percent i feel that way you
know i would tell you if i didn't think
you were a good wrestler appreciate that
most nba players don't say most a lot of
nba players
try to rap aren't great
rappers would you agree with that i
would agree with that
okay what other nba players do you feel
yeah do you feel like
they can also genuinely rap i think iman
schumper can rap
i think lonzo ball can rap really
i mean it's not my type of rap i rap
like the music that i listen to like nas
and common
so i rap like that storytelling and like
basically telling my reality when they
lose people is when they come out and
they start rapping about them playing
basketball
that's the fastest way to get people to
be like this dude corny yeah what i'm
saying when they start talking about how
they
drop 30 on somebody or dead like don't
talk about it just leave that alone
why do people think that you can't rap
and play basketball why is that
i don't know it's a good question we got
a lot more time on our hands than people
think yeah
i can't let you leave without asking you
this every friday
you have rappers send in freestyles for
four bar friday
yeah once you got this one float you
know i mean it's been a grip
but i pull up like i'm parking i'm tony
starks with the talking so that's mark
twain in the mark 10 doing mock five
going over your head like a pup
fly if you want to put everybody on the
spot i gotta put you on the spot you
gotta give me
four bars about this interview what
what it's only fair i told taylor take
me there she said where i say a special
place
i dream about equality a nightmare we
segregate
represent the people pave a way for us
to elevate love one and educate instead
of stressing medicaid
for bars much love you ready
um wrapping up with damn lately it was
good
how'd it feel it felt great yes blazer's
very own wing
i can't wing either
what's up you guys it's taylor brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more
video content